and you love the ocean I understand I  love that yeah I my father raised me  around the ocean and I was scuba diving  and by the time I was ten you know I was  fishing ever since I could hold a pole  and so I I lived in Hawaii for a while  and I've served for 25 years and scuba  dive and all that sort of things yeah  any analogy and surfing that applies to  navigating an acting career Oh easily I  love seeing all these people now that  you know they're all surfers you know  Matthew McConaughey but I understand why  I do because you can only be in the  moment it's like rock climbing I used to  be a rock climber as well you can only  be in the moment when you're doing that  or you're gonna get in you're just gonna  wipe out in not such a good way and one  has to feel the the motion of the nature  of the beast that you're on and so yeah  I learned a lot a lot about endurance  and and keeping my eyes open  certainly  you